uh all right we have we have a
correction
we have a story from uh veritas but the
we mentioned earlier that the guy was a
lead engineer he's not the client it's
my fault but let's read this story with
a tweet from lydia leaderman oh who's
that who's that breaking lighterman
lighterman i pronounce
twitter lead client partner says woke
ideology responsible for inability to
profit
affirms twitter not here to give people
free speech refuses taking elon musk
seriously due to asperger's making him
special there we go well now here's the
issue
i like the first thing he said but the
ableism just gets to me it's
it is problematic
let's uh let's hear what this man has to
say well right now
okay let me fix the other club
also is this another date
i think so yes yeah this is how you do
it well to be fair these guys probably
make pretty good money so it's probably
pretty easy for them to get dates sure
right i mean
look if you're a guy on tinder you know
how many how many you you swipe right a
hundred times you get back how many
messages yeah i don't want to talk about
it
so it's gonna say ideology which is what
led us to not be profitable
the rest of us who have been here
believe in something that's good for the
planet and not just to
give people free speech
because again like these people really
do believe in what we're doing it's a
cult he literally said it's for the
better betterment of the planet like is
that in the green new deal yeah what are
you talking about imagine aoc makes the
green no deal and it's like we will buy
twitter elon can't own twitter these are
the policies we've put in place for
misinformation or
mislabeling media
why do you think this should be taken
down yeah
like those are the questions they're
gonna ask
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be hard for
him to be like
oh because people should make their own
decision it's like no but people don't
know how to make a rational decision if
you don't
put out all the correct things that are
supposed to be out there like the hunter
by the laptop story he's correct yeah
like the 100 story like russiagate like
ukraine gate like the covington kids
like jessie smallett like trayvon martin
like ahmed arbory oh man like ghost of
gift wow the list goes on and on and on
like wmds in iraq and all of that good
juicy stuff he's completely right i got
very excited when you said wmds i'm like
finally what i'm allowed to agree with i
agree with that one don't get me in
trouble i remember that i remember the
war in iraq it's bad
follow me on twitter
so this guy my favorite by the way was
during that kind of slurred rant seeing
the person he was out with slowly pick
up the wine glass as he's just rambling
what did you notice i also one thing i
loved
the way he said it he's like oh people
can make their own decisions
okay
great pretty much so uh
i noticed something
did you notice something about this
video that is different from the other
video i don't think you saw the other
video though
was it it's a dude right
it's a dude that means it's not tender
that means it's grinding grinder
it's a grinder date spicy
advertiser as my business is what i do
every day and why i go out is like we
want it to be
as
fair and transparent and
accurate as possible yeah and if that
means
there's a level of censorship to make it
correct quote unquote again and what
does correct mean i guess like it just
kind of goes into the idea of like well
what is correct if we're implementing
all these rules that there's and ela
wants to dismantle them
then technically
our ideology has led us to not making
money
because we're not making money
and he wants to turn it the other way so
that we can make money there's a
statement they need all 7 000 people to
say and so they can't like tell us the
like
the real truth he has hospitals yes yeah
i know that
so he's special your
special needs you're literally special
needs so
i can't even take what you're saying
seriously
wait wait you can read it let me see
how to protect yourself
groups like project veritas or actors
that second i would end the date like uh
okay oh you don't know how to pronounce
veritas no no no no 100 you know that's
the veritas journalist no i know i know
that's what i'm saying it's it's
he's like i've never heard of this
wonderful sounding organization why does
twitter dislike them jams okay
wait wait wait hold on i'm gonna go back
a little bit he starts talking about it
it's like some group that's trying to
just out the employees like they're
trying to you know this one dates with
that this is from like yesterday
this is like how obvious does a trap
have to be
project veritas he's like let me tell
you everything i think about that you
know what i love acorn yeah hey he's
like he's like this wonderful
organization acorn they got destroyed i
mean this person this is the ultimate if
you are doing a sting operation and your
mark
shows you
your other successful sting operation
it's just gold you're like i am killing
that by the way well this is this is the
fault of those those dating coaches who
are telling people to repeat every
incriminating thing about themselves on
their first date with a stranger wait is
this a big thing no i'm i'm being sorry
i have no idea no because i've
definitely done that on first dates
where i was just like sit down and let
me tell you a tale of a website called
jezebel uh i've done that on first date
so it's like do not suggest yeah the
twitter guy sits down and he's like uh
hello i'm john uh and you're janet nice
to meet you i commit crimes at twitter i
disparage people who are lesser than me
and i want to rule the world and that's
our goal for the company and we're going
to steal money from people it's like
well that was something weird to lead
with
all right let's play more also like this
and record them and then go sell it to
the new york times and say this is what
the twitter employee just said this is
what's really happening this is what
they're telling us tonight
you're lucky that you met me organically
because i would be questioning
everything about you
that's brutal oh they just put that in
there to hurt the man they just put that
in there to hurt them there was no
reason to include that in this story
dude that's a cartoon that didn't really
happen no none of that really happened
to the camera we are being set up right
now camera tim this is the someone's
reporting misinformation
we're not
how could you do this to me i didn't
mean to he's like we were ruining the
news you're not part of that project
veritas you would never hurt me this is
ridiculous dude uh
i'm telling you we're about to hear
sirens the house is being surrounded
right now this is us being set up right
one million percent no they're like
filming us i don't know through the
computer somehow oh my gosh we have
webcams on our computer we're being set
up they want to see your response to it
let me play this
again
you're lucky that you met me organically
because i would be questioning
everything about you
yo that was like that hurt my soul that
was i know it's like very creepy
like he gets real close to him he does
get kind of questionable yeah he knows
do you guys think he knew
i mean it looks like it but he or but he
said everything he wasn't supposed to
say right yeah but he literally looked
into that
suspicious of project veritas and he
goes on a date and tells the person he
knows everything and shows them the
emails
i don't oh let me i got to tell you guys
a story i once worked for a news
organization
and uh we were getting spearfishing
emails
so do you guys know what spearfishing is
like the actual sport or is it some
weird email it's it's a hacker term yep
i knew it so uh phishing is when you'll
get a random email that says like um
sign up today click here yep you do and
then it tries to get you you give your
password a spear phishing attack
is when they spoof an email
and so
we were getting emails from higher-ups
at this company to us saying hey there's
a big story check it out right here and
i'm not an idiot so as soon as i saw it
i laughed it had like the wrong title
for the for the for the staff member i
brought it to the cto and i was like hey
we're getting phishing attempts i was
like maybe it's just me and he was like
no everybody got it and i was like oh
for real he's like and 25 people flicked
it
and i went i was like yup
and then i was like didn't they realize
their boss wasn't that position and they
were like they didn't think about it
and so
they locked it up right away yeah here's
where it gets really good
so then a few days later we all get
basic phishing attacks
where it's an email from a company that
shouldn't have never heard of and it's
like sign up today click here and i
laugh
and so i go to the cto again and i say
i'm getting more phishing attempts and
he's like i know i know i know we'll
we'll deal with it
and then a few hours later a
company-wide email from the cto goes out
saying guys i told you not to click
these links you if you've clicked any of
these links you now need to reset your
password
with a link
and as soon as i saw it i went to the
cto and i was like bro
this was the best spear phishing attack
ever that's incredible the cto never
sent out an email that was the attack
clever and then he was like wait what
happened and i was like it came from you
dude they spoofed your email
they were
here's why i bring this up because
hackers are hilarious it was i was
laughing
and the cto was like he was stressed but
he was like that was good that's
incredible that wasn't it was a very
clever manipulation like it was a
three-layered attack but here's why i
bring the story up for one i love that
story of like the hacker move how they
broke into the system i'm in but the
best part is
this guy working for twitter
is sent a warning email yep from there
people like guys be on the lookout don't
do this and he goes i'm gonna do exactly
what they told me not to do with this
stranger look he's like i'm gonna get
some tail also these are not sexy
stories to talk about
like if you're getting that email just
bring up something else dude i'd like to
issue an apology and retraction it was
not a grinder date it was oh no
they're better again
organically
right right i can't grinder hq yeah yeah
i can't wait
outside i can't wait to finally see the
veritas video where it's like at the
altar at their wedding yeah he's like
yeah he's just going on about his job
and the corrupt things they're doing
look at this crazy look at this email
it's their 25th wedding anniversary the
priest is like uh we will now have the
bride and groom read their vows and then
he's like when i first met you i was
working for a large bank i was funneling
money to private corporations in paris
oh my gosh no dude and the priest is
like he's a fake priest he's also
internet he's like if you have any
intimidating information about yourself
you may now say it
her children from a past marriage have
tiny mustaches and they're wearing
trench coats
yeah we gotta we have to get we have to
do the skit we have to get james in on
it we have to that'll be a scary like we
get like a small young woman sitting in
front of the guy and he goes wait a
minute and when he grabs her hair and
pulls it down it's just a full like six
foot called james o'keefe in a suit
this is like the twitter version of to
catch a predator
where every time they're like i'm gonna
get away you're not from that crazy
msnbc show and then chris hansen what we
do that with james o'keefe like why
don't you have a scene why don't you
take a scene over there
what part of you thought this made any
sense
dude uh i'm not kidding we should legit
do those that would be funny my legit
advice by the way when you're out on
dates ask about the other person yeah no
seriously they're like those are
insufferable so these people are getting
caught monologuing which we know is not
something
exactly for a first date i gotta say too
i genuinely think this guy knew what was
up he saw that email he's like here's a
guy i'm gonna meet him in a bar and i'm
gonna tell him that he did no villain
headphones oh weird right yeah yeah but
if you met someone randomly you wouldn't
think it but he just got that email he
has a tweet also some of these people
are just sociopaths they're just
narcissists where they're like yeah i'm
picking up people randomly i don't have
anything to worry about blah blah blah
instead of i mean
meeting organically is almost
more suspect than tinder because tinder
there are so many options so many
options i mean essentially this dude
just walks up to you
i mean that's you were targeted that
that to me is easier to spot do you
think so do you think that veritas has
like a dossier on the twitter employees
and so they send out like a young dude
to this bar and they're like your target
is this man he pulls up the photograph
and he's like yeah i'm gonna go on his
type like looked up like exes on
facebook and stuff
and then he shows up in project veritas
this sounds very fun
it does sound fun doesn't it like
until you have to break their heart oh
yeah you guys think this is a laughing
matter no i would fall in love that's
why i fall in
we've already written love really funny
bits we should do one is where it's like
the the the teen drama where the jock
dates the ugly girl because he was dared
to do it that's great it's like i was
watching
it's become something else but then the
other one is the sting goes all the way
to like to marriage that no i wanted to
go further like i would do it like it
starts with them getting married and
then there's like the next thing is the
guy's 25th wedding anniversary the next
one is like in the hospital dying with
his wife he's been married to his entire
life
after that is like both of them
strangely periodically there's a there's
different men like doing work and
they're all james o'keefe like
one day they're like
man
[Laughter]
he still gets milk
[Laughter]
just gonna just gonna fix the cable here
and he's just like positioning his his
jacket he's like literally setting up
cameras like no it's the cable it's for
the cable
dude i'm not kidding we should legit do
it all right one million percent i will
stand another day to film this yeah
let's
we'll see we gotta have james fly out
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at eight
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you